Idaho Senator Chuck Winder
suggests that abortion is to blame for Idaho's work shortages
we complain about
we don't have service workers
we don't have enough of this
we don't have enough people to do this
well I think there's a reason not
it's not just low birth rate
but it is the number of abortions that have occurred
before diving into how absurd of a statement that is
let's be clear that even if abortions were causing a worker shortage
women do not owe anyone
including their government
their bodies or reproductive labor
forced birth is not a policy solution to Idaho's problems
which I'll get to in a second
Idaho's abortion rate has been quite low in stagnant since the early 2000s
with about 1000 to 1500 abortions being performed each year
and just last week
the US Chamber of Commerce released new data
Idaho has about 55,000 job openings and about 28,000 unemployed individuals
so obviously the math isn't mathing
but even if it was
his statement has a bunch of just incorrect logical fallacies
he's assuming that if we forced all of these women to have given birth
that they all would have resulted in a healthy pregnancy
a healthy baby that would turn into a healthy adult
that would choose to stay and work in Idaho
and he makes one of the most common Republican logical fallacies
which is that if we just forced all of these women
who have historically had abortions
to have given birth
that we would have a net increase in population
no research shows that
let's say we have two women
we have Sam and Sarah
and they both want an abortion
Sam is denied an abortion
but Sarah receives the wanted abortion
Sam is much less likely to have planned
planned pregnancies later on in her life
versus Sarah
who is much more likely to have planned pregnancies later on in her life
so Sam may end up having one child
while despite having the abortion
Sarah ends up having three
to the extent that Idaho is experiencing a lower than typical birth rate
let's just appreciate how dangerous it is to be pregnant in Idaho
from 2019 to 2021
the maternal mortality rate in Idaho rose 121%
while the child an infant
mortality rate rose 18%
then Idaho Republicans enacted one of the country's strictest abortion bans
and being aware of research that shows that
that will increase maternal mortality
guess what they did
they dissolved the committee who is tasked with investigating maternal mortality
maternal services like prenatal care and Obgyns
are becoming much and much more scarce in the state
as Obgyns and other doctors flee
because of the strict abortion ban
one in five Idaho moms do not receive any prenatal care in the first trimester
and that number is even lower for women of color
and three in 10 Idaho moms
did not have health insurance before becoming pregnant
2023 Idaho Republicans rejected $6 million in free
federal funding to support child care and early childhood development
because they
and this is a quote
didn't wanna make it more convenient for mothers to leave the home
it infuriates me that these men are in power
men who don't understand us
see us value us
or our lives
who feel entitled to our bodies and reproductive organs and decisions
who blame us for the consequences of their bad policy making
it's a level of entitlement and cruelty
and willful ignorance
that I don't know that I will ever be able to understand
I'm the feminist lawyer
follow me if you enjoy being miserable